كثافه السلطات التركيه في الاونه الاخيره
ما تقول انه حمله ضد المهاجرين غير
النظاميين الى الشمال السوري رحل عدد من
السوريين من الاراضي التركيه اكد وزير
الداخليه التركيه ان الحمله الامنيه لا
تستهدف حاملي وثائق الحمايه المؤقته
[موسيقى]
لماذا زادت عمليات ترحيل اللاجئين في
تركيا
استغلت المعارضه ملف اللاجئين ورقه للضغط
على الحكومه وهو ما اثر في سير الانتخابات
الرئاسيه الاخيره اذ لم يتمكن الدغال من
حسم النصر في الجوله الاولى بعد ان حصل
تحالف الشعب المعارض على اربعه واربعين
بالمئه وتسعه وثمانين جزءا من المئه من
اصوات ناخبين ونال سنان اوغان مرشح تحالف
الاجداد خمسه بالمئه وسبعه عشر جزءا من
المئه وهي نسبه خاجات السياسيين والشارع
التركيه على حد سواء فعز المراقبون الامر
الى مناهضه اوغانا للاجئين في بلاده ما
اظهر تاثير شريحه واسعه بسياسه ترحيل
لاجئهم وتحالف اردوغان معه في الجوله
الثانيه وزاد مع التحالف تصريحات الحكومه
باعاده نحو مليون لاجئ طوعا وترحيل غير
نظاميين الى الوجهات التي
ما ابرز الجنسيات اللاجئين في تركيا
يبلغ عدد الاجانب في تركيا بحسب دائره
الهجره اربعه ملايين
الف شخص ويقدر عدد السوريين بثلاثه ملايين
وثلاثمائه
المؤقته عاد منهم قبل الانتخابات الاخيره
طوعا نحو
50000 يليهم في المرتبه الثانيه العراقيون
بما يقارب 700 الف شخص وبعدهم الافغان
بعدد يصل الى 500 الف تقريبا رحل منهم حتى
شهر نيسان من العام الجاري قرابه 12 الفا
ما الاثر المتوقع في الانتخابات المحليه
المجمع عقلها في عام
يرى الصحفيان محمود جوز ارسلان
ان دوافع الترحيل الاخيره سياسيه بحته وان
الحكومه تسع من خلالها لتقديم دعايه
الانتخابيه مسبقه وذلك بعد ان خس بلديه
الولايات الكبرى مثل انقره واسطنبول وصارت
تدرك ان المعارضه كسبت تاييدا لتبنيها
خطابا معاديا
[موسيقى]
كده